let me thank the over 5,000 people in
the state of Vermont who emailed called
and wrote to me and said do not support
legislation that will allow the
President of the United States to
unleash a unilateral attack against Iraq
demand that the president work with the
United Nations and with the
international community to get weapons
inspectors into Iraq that's what the
people of Vermont have told me and poll
after poll shows that that is what the
people of the United States want we may
have been in the minority today but I
have no doubt that we are representing
the vast majority of the people who are
scared to death about the possibility
that the United States could set a
precedent of a unilateral invasion of a
country which could trigger disastrous
results from China Russia and every
other country in the world who will then
say if the United States thinks it can
go to war anytime it wants why can we in
China not do the same we in Russia not
do the same second point that I want to
make is that many of us are hearing from
our constituents that maybe instead of
talking about Iraq every single day and
having the media talking about Iraq
every single day maybe we should be
protecting elderly people have lost
their life savings in a declining stock
market maybe we should protecting the
millions of American workers who have
seen their jobs go to China and Mexico
maybe we should be talking about the
fact that our health care system is
collapsing and insurance rates are going
up and many of us are sick and tired
that the White House is not focusing on
the issues that reflect the needs of
concerns of tens and tens of millions of
Americans what we all believe is that
working together with the united nations
with the international community we can
resolve this problem without a
unilateral American invasion